dans tous les hôpitaux de France la même
scène de Paris à Toulouse en passant par
Marseille et Reims bien sûr la minute de
silence a été respectée avec partout les
mêmes sentiments d'émotion et puis les
mêmes questions qu'est-ce qui se passe
on a un hôpital qui est va mal qui est
déjà pauvre et à l'intérieur de ça on a
une psychiatrie qui est pas en pauvre
dans l'hôpital derrière notre peine il y
a ce sentiment d'injustice
il y a cette volonté de protection
les ministres travaillent pour que
toutes les mesures soient prises pour la
sécurité de celles et ceux qui nous
soignent un contexte de violence accrue
envers les soignants envers nos mères on
parlait encore il y a quelques jours
tous les ténors de la gauche étaient
présents à Saint-Brévin Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Olivier Ford écologiste marine
tondeuillier le mérianique Morez lui n'a
pas participé à la marche regrettant
justement cette récupération politique
un grand merci et c'est vrai que depuis
une semaine je suis pris dans un
tourbillon médiatique depuis l'annonce
de ma démission et quand il démène la
récupération politique et notamment par
l'extrême gauche vous répondez quoi je
crois pas sincèrement qu'il y ait de
récupération de qui que ce soit
manifeste contre l'extrême droite contre
les intimidations les pressions et la
violence de l'extrême droite l'extrême
gauche essaye de se refaire la cerise
sur son dos donc moi il y a pas de
récupération
s de l'extrême gauche il n'y a aucune
montée de récupération on n'est pas venu
avec des drapeaux du PS de la France
insoumise des écologistes ou du Parti
communiste on est venu en fait avec nos
écharpes tricolores simplement pour dire
que ici nous défendons des idées des
valeurs qui sont celles de tous les
républicains
limité parlementaire du député et ancien
ministre d'Amiens Abad a été levé ce
matin à l'unanimité du bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est aussi ce que
souhaitait le principal intéressé Damien
Abad pour adorer l'avant être placé en
garde à vue ce qui n'était pas possible
jusqu'à lors on s'est levé pour faire
une minute d'applaudissements en
l'honneur de Yannick Brévin j'ai pas
compris que l'extrême droite ne se lève
pas qu'à ce moment-là elle reste assise
les bras croisés qu'est-ce que ça
signifie Emmanuel Macron ce matin à
qualifier en des termes très spécifiques
le climat actuel qui règne en France oui
c'est un terme fort voir très fort en
formation du Parisien confirmé par BFM
TV il emploie le terme de des
civilisations alors c'est quoi Guyane a
une adolescente est soupçonnée d'avoir
mis le feu à son dortoir dans un
internat parce que son portable lui
avait été confisqué les conséquences
sont terribles 19 jeunes ont perdu la
vie je le cite à des violences jamais
justifiables quel que soit les causes
aucune violence des légitime puis il
ajoute j'appelle le gouvernement à
travailler en profondeur en profondeur
contre ce processus de décibilisation et
puis Marine Le Pen entendu par la
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
des soupçons d'ingérence étrangères au
cœur de cette audition un pré contractée
par le rassemblement national en 2014
on avance un peu
le signe après avec une banque je signe
pas après que Vladimir Poutine
voilà sinon tous vous avez signé des
prêts avec Macron bah oui non mais
d'accord mais Mexique s'inquiète du
regain d'activité du popo ktpelte le
volcan en situé à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres de Mexico crachent des fumées
et descendre ce qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences je signe avec une banque ça
ne m'engage absolument à rien et si ça
m'avait engagé à quelque chose monsieur
le Président je n'aurais pas signé ce
prêt c'est clair je ne l'aurais pas
signé l'islamologue Tariq Ramadan était
poursuivi en Suisse pour viol et
contrainte sexuelle dans une affaire qui
remonte à 2008 il a été acquitté ce
mercredi le procureur avait requis trois
ans de prison dont la moitié avec sursis
le tribunal a jugé qu'il n'y avait pas
suffisamment d'éléments contre lui
que cnews est un média de guerre civile
que nous sommes une chaîne de haine et
xénophobe monsieur pleinel est reçu en
majesté par la plupart de mes confrères
par conviction ou par crainte j'espère
que ce verdict
soulèvera les consciences parce qu'il
n'y a rien de pire que d'être accusé
d'un crime qu'on n'a pas commis il est à
mes yeux l'incarnation de Tartuffe faux
dévot qui avance drapé dans le manteau
de la morale pour mieux cacher son âme
sombre et ses passions tristes